قالت وسائل اعلام ان الاتحاد الاوروبي
يعتزم نشر ما سماه مهمه عسكريه مدنيه في
غرب افريقيا تشمل نشر ضباط وجنود في ساحل
العاج وغانا وتوجو وبنين كان هذا خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما
دلالات واعتزام الاتحاد الاوروبي نشر ما
يقول انها مهمه عسكريه مدنيه في غرب
افريقيا وما مغزى تزامن القرار الاوروبي
مع جوله مساعده وزير الخارجيه الامريكي في
عدد من دول المنطقه على اي نحو يمكن ان
ينعكس هذا الاهتمام الغربي المتزايد
بمنطقه غرب افريقيا على مسار انقلاب
النيجر
اهم يحملون صفه المستشارين اول مدربين
وصحيحهم ينتمون الى القوات العسكريه لكن
لا يمكن تسميتها قوه مسلحه مهمه التي هي
اصلا مجدوله في برنامج السياسه الخارجيه
للاتحاد الاوروبي لهدفين الهدف الاول هو
مواصله اعطاء النصح والتدريب القوات
المسلحه في هذه في هذه الدول ضد الجماعات
المسلحه بالاضافه كذلك وهو الهدف الثاني
والهدف الاساسي اعتقد وهو كيف يمكن مجابهه
التوغل الروسي في المنطقه الان اعتقد ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي يحاول ان يوازن بين
وجوده والصعود الروسي والصيني في المناطق
الافريقيه ايضا مكافحه موجات الهجره التي
تنبثق من النيجر والمناطق المحيطه به جهود
الان تتحرك نحو دول غرب افريقيا بشكل
متصاعد من اجلي منع سيناريو الدول الساحل
ربما قد تكون هذه الجهود متاخره نوعا لكن
الجهود في منطقه الساحل كانت موجوده لوقت
طويل لسوء الحظ هي لم تحقق اهدافها التي
كانت مؤمنه هذا الاوروبي لديه وجود قويه
في منطقه الساحل وفي الشرق الاوسط بوركينا
فاسو وفي جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى لكن بحسب
الاحداث التي شهدناها فمن كان من الضروري
سحب هذه القوات الاوروبيه من مجموعه من
الدول الافريقيه
[موسيقى]
ما هي جوله استطلاعيه لتحديد ما الذي هو
ممكن في دول غربي افريقيا والساحل وهي
ايضا تزور تشاد وهي جار ساحلي الى النيجر
وايضا سيكون بالتاكيد هنالك نقاشات ما
يمكن القيام به في النيجر
على المكاسب
والحيلوله دون وقوع دول اخرى او مناطق
اخرى تحت سيطره اما التنظيمات تنظيمات
مسلحه ارهابيه او كذلك تحت التاثير الروسي
المتحده كانت واضحه في دعمها للاستمرار
الحكم الديمقراطي في النيجر وايضا واكدت
واعاده الرئيس بزومعه
لسده الرئاسه هناك وهذا الوضع الذي
عبرت عنه
وصل الى نفس التقي والان سياسه فرنسا في
ازمه وحتى المقاربه الفرنسيه للخروج من
هذه الازمه في صعوبه كبيره ليس هناك حل
بديل عن حل الدبلوماسي هناك بعض الدول
طبعا تضغط باتجاه الحاله العسكري لكنها
وصلت الى خلاصه الى ليس هناك بديل عن الحل
الدبلوماسي
يمكن القول بان احداث النيجر هي التي سرعت
في ارسال هذه المهمه ليس هناك اجماع على
التدخل العسكري اذا الاتحاد الاوروبي
الافريقي بالاحرار كان دائما يدعو للتدخل
السلمي لحل هذه
الاتحاد الاوروبي عشر تمثيليات عسكريه
مدنيه في العالم سبعه منها في افريقيا مما
يعني ان لافريقيا مكان مهمه في
الاستراتيجيه الاوروبيه الان هناك شعور
مناوب ومعادي لفرنسا وفرنسا كانت دائما هي
التي تقود مختلف المهمات
الاوروبيه لا يمكن لي قوات اوروبيه او
تواجد اوروبي في النهايه يعني يعوض
التواجد الفرنسي الذي كان فعلا يعني عندما
لديك قوه باكثر اكثر من 1500 هذا وتكون
لديك بعثه بمئه شخص من الصعب جدا تحقيق
الاهداف التي تريدها فرنسا او الاتحاد
الاوروبي الولايات المتحده ترغب برؤيه بعض
الت في مساله قطع العلاقات مع القوات
الجهاديه والقضاء عليها من الولايه
المتحده وجهودها تهدف الى عمل مع الافارقه
ومع الاوروبيين من اجل ايقاف هذا الامر
وضعي
برامج تدريبيه وجهد